good morning Hank it's Tuesday I want to
talk today about Boko Haram which was
formed in Nigeria in 2002 but I want to
begin in the year 1100
in fact in many places including
sub-saharan Africa Islam spread
primarily by trade so back in the Year
1100 is leaders in what is now northern
Nigeria started to convert to Islam they
were trading with North African barbers
and by the 18th century most of the
people in what is now northern Nigeria
and also what is now southwestern
Nigeria were Muslims but those
sub-saharan African empires never spread
to the rest of southern Nigeria so those
people were not Muslims instead in the
19th century when a bunch of European
missionaries showed up many of those
people in the rest of southern Nigeria
became Christians what is now Nigeria
was colonized by the British for much of
the 20th century but northern Nigeria
was controlled by what's known as
indirect rule like the local Amir's were
allowed to run everything as long as
they pledged allegiance to the British
and also paid them a portion of their
money now as far as colonization goes
that seems like a pretty good deal but
it also meant that there was much less
western-style education in northern
Nigeria than in southern Nigeria which
was much more directly ruled by the
British so the south ended up with most
of the doctors and the lawyers and the
bureaucrats also all of the oil is in
the south I should pause here to say
that this is of course oversimplified
there are hundreds of languages spoken
in Nigeria and hundreds of different
ethnic groups ceremony Christians living
in predominantly Muslim communities many
Muslims living in predominantly
Christian communities so it's definitely
not as simple as it divided between
north and south but there is a big gap
there okay so one of the many
catastrophes of colonization is that it
created borders that were convenient to
Europeans but not necessarily to the
people who like lived in the actual
places so in 1960 Nigeria gains
independence which is awesome except
it's never actually been like a unified
political entity I think this is famous
moment in James Joyce's novel Ulysses
where Leopold Bloom is asked what a
nation is and Blum answers a nation is
the same people living in the same place
or also living in different places but
1960 Nigeria was more like different
people living in the same place which
went to a bunch of coos and then
eventually to a 1967 civil war parts of
southern Nigeria seceded and became the
Republic of Biafra and the rest of
Nigeria was like wait no we should be
one Nigeria also all the oil is in your
new country there was a hue
Civil War for two and a half years more
than a million people died in the end
Nigeria won and the Republic of Biafra
ceased to exist and the country was
reunited so Nigeria today is a really
interesting country it's split almost
evenly between Christians and Muslims it
has one of the fastest-growing economies
in the world and very little national
debt it's the largest economy in Africa
and the 20th largest in the world their
film industry generates ten billion
dollars in sales a year but it's also
the last nation in Africa that still has
polio which is found only in the north
and life expectancy in Nigeria is 52
that's lower than it is in Somalia which
doesn't even have a government in much
of northern Nigeria fewer than half of
kids even go to elementary school female
illiteracy is over 50% and while the
country's overall economy grows at over
8% a year in the north absolute poverty
is actually increasing hey it's easy
enough to say that religion is the
problem here right except there are a
lot of Muslims living in the southwest
of Nigeria where female literacy is over
90% and the economy is growing really
well the problem is partly resource
allocation like Nigeria's export economy
is just a smidge dependent upon
petroleum which is found almost
exclusively in the south but there's
also all these legacies of colonialism
and indirect rule which means less
effective federal governance and
everything from education to the Armed
Forces so this was the northern Nigeria
that saw Boko Haram emerge in 2002 a
region disproportionately impoverished
uneducated and poorly governed the words
Boko Haram literally mean Western
education is forbidden
the group is founded by a guy named
Mohammad youssuf who himself had a
western-style education and spoke
English although he believed that the
earth is flat and that rain is not
caused by evaporation so maybe it wasn't
such a great education in 2002 he began
recruiting unemployed young people into
his movement railing against official
corruption which is rampant and also
advocating for the creation of an
Islamist state but Boko Haram didn't
actually become a military organization
until Yousef was arrested and then
shortly thereafter executed in 2009 over
a thousand people were killed in the
riots that followed Mohammad youssuf
execution and after that Boko Haram
became increasingly militant and crazy I
mean this is an organization that claims
they want to restore like righteousness
and justice to Nigeria but they fund
themselves like primarily through drug
trafficking and bank robbery in 2011
Boko Haram was behind Nigeria's
first-ever soo
side bombing on Christmas of that year
they killed 41 people via bombings and
shootings at churches in 2012 they
killed at least 792 people and in 2013
they murdered nine women who were
distributing polio vaccines polio
vaccines they also murdered 54 mostly
Muslim college students while they were
sleeping in their dorms and then in 2014
Boko Haram got worldwide attention when
they kidnapped 276 girls from inside of
classrooms the attacks since then have
only gotten worse On January 3rd of this
year they seized the town of Baga burned
it to the ground murdered as many as
2,000 people and now Boko Haram controls
the northeastern corner of Nigeria where
they've instituted a version of Sharia
law so extreme that not only has the
likes of it never been seen in
sub-saharan Africa but it's like too
extreme for al-qaeda they regularly
Massacre people who won't fight for them
and they've begun attacks in Niger and
Chad and Cameroon Boko Haram still has
an army of between seven and ten
thousand people and it's difficult to
understand what those people are
thinking at least what the leaders are
thinking I mean they can script a lot of
people they have lots of child soldiers
they force preteen girls to be suicide
bombers and it's hard to understand that
evil then again I don't know if I need
to understand it but I do need to know
about it I mean not knowing about this
stuff is really problematic because one
of the great tragedies of Boko Haram is
that they've been allowed to grow for
the last ten years because the Nigerian
government and the world community
haven't done a good enough job of
noticing how terrible they are so I
think it's really important to learn
about Boko Haram and not let their
atrocities go unnoticed but I also think
it's important to understand that
literally 99.9 percent of Nigerians do
not support Boko Haram I think it's also
important to remember that just a few
days ago two Muslim volunteers in a
northern town sacrificed their lives to
keep a Boko Haram suicide bomber from
entering a city market where she would
have killed hundreds of people Hank I'll
see you on Friday